surveying the danger zone in Vinton
Berga Chancellor Merkel stressed the
government would do everything in its
power to assist residents hit by the
floods she was trying to give people in
the affected area some hope as they
banded together against the elements
seeing how people stick together in
difficult times we can be proud of our
country this sign in Magdeburg reads
thanks to our helpers the river has
crested and the Elbe is slowly receding
but water is still everywhere volunteers
and soldiers are working almost around
the clock
we're running shifts of up to 20 hours
then we hole up somewhere for some rest
maybe two hours and then it's back to
work but the danger is far from over
many bulwarks are under severe strain
hundreds of residents of fishbeck in
saxony-anhalt fled their homes early
Monday after a nearby levee gave way the
village is now submerged it's feared
many here have lost everything in
southern Germany cleanup efforts are
well underway a week after the Danube
flooded the town of des Gondorff
residents are using all available means
to recover what they can but some parts
of the town still look like lakes and
where the waters have receded the extent
of the damage becomes clear these
people's lives have been upended by the
flood of 2013